les banques au chevet des entreprises
face à la crise sanitaire dans cet
établissement près de 1700 pme ont été
contactés dans les yvelines
la priorité l'écouté le conseil des
chefs d'entreprise d'abord leurs
principales préoccupations comme la
nomme d'ailleurs ce fut leurs
collaborateurs donc comment les mettre
en sécurité
comment organiser le chômage partiel
derrière leur priorité c'était la
trésorerie malheureusement le chiffre
d'affaires diminuant fortement voire
s'arrêter brutalement les charges
continuant il nous faut autoriser des
découverts qui vont au delà des
autorisations classique
face aux interrogations aux difficultés
des banques proposent aussi aux
entreprises de reporter les échéances
des crédits déjà en cours dès dès les
premiers moments de cette crise
sanitaire nous avons décidé en fait de
mettre en place les reports d'échéances
donc ça c'est un gros travail qui est
dit mise en place de puits et maintenant
deux semaines et demie au crédit
agricole d'île de france plus de 500
report d'échéance de crédit ont été
demandées dans les yvelines